now more on our breaking news story out
of Israel let's bring in Imran Khan he's
our correspondent joining us once again
from Tel Aviv Imran so the defense
minister of fire tell us what you're
hearing
well the word room is swirling around
all day that this may well happen and it
did happen about half an hour ago now
this actually all began on Thursday
night yoga land before now Former
Defense Minister was supposed to issue a
statement instead he was called to
Jerusalem and Netanyahu the Prime
Minister and Garland had a meeting and
then that statement was called off in
that statement he was going to say that
the judicial overhaul Bill needed to be
halted then on Saturday night he
actually issued the statement uh
unilaterally this apparently angered
Benjamin Netanyahu who then applied him
but one of the reasons that angered
Benjamin Netanyahu is because four other
members of his own party backed you of
Gallant now this was going to put strain
on the Coalition it was going to put a
strain on the government if those four
members of the canessa decided that they
weren't going to vote then the Prime
Minister would lose his majority and the
bill would not be passed now he's
actually been replaced Now by a guy
called Avi dixaby dictator was a former
head of the shinbeth Israeli
intelligence agency he's a loyalist to
Netanyahu and he's already come out and
said that he will back the judicial
overhaul bill this is a very crucial
time for Israel where a whole we're
going into the Passover parliamentary
recess in about a week's time the
protesters are out on the streets in
large number they're protesting every
single day now there's a large protest
due to take place outside of parliament
on Wednesday and cracks are appearing
within uh the coalition government like
I say these four members of the liquid
party they would have been able to kill
any attempts to pass this bill
getting rid of yo of Gallant is a bold
bold move for prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu but it's a bold move that he
continues to play he always goes for
loyalists you have Galant was seen by
many as being a compromised candidate
for that job he was seen as an adult in
the room and a voice of reason well that
voice of reason has now been removed and
so this paves the way for the judicial
overhaul Bill to be passed before the
Passover holiday that's coming uh in
just a week's time
okay Imran we'll let you go for now
thank you so much for that update from
Tel Aviv let's bring in a political
analyst Akiva Eldar he's joining us from
Tel Aviv as well so um what's your
reaction to this Mr Elder did this come
as a surprise
I I believe that uh the game is not over
yet and we are heading towards uh
Israel's uh worst
uh political
and the judicial prices I think that the
age will end uh in uh a head-on
collision between the the government and
the knesset on one hand and the
Judiciary uh and uh the high court is
already being challenged by an NGO uh
asking to uh declare the Prime Minister
incompetent incompetent of leading the
country and uh actually abusing his
power by ignoring the uh conflict of
interest agreement between him and the
Supreme Court and uh I believe that
we are looking at a kind of a worse
conflict between the heads of the Secret
Service the Army the police that will
have a will have to make up their mind
if they follow the orders of the
government or the law so
what do the next sort of 24 to 48 hours
look like in your opinion
um first of all I believe that the
liquid the majority of uh really good
faction in the knesset will stand behind
Netanyahu not because they like this
situation it's just because
um there is a kind of uh I would even
say a kind of a kingdom uh in in the
liquid Natalia is not just a prime
minister he is uh the the king of the
likud and he can fire any Minister like
he did today to galat and uh appoint
someone else
okay thank you Akiva Eldar thank you for
joining us from Tel Aviv on this
breaking news story